У нас нічого не залишилось! Ой, я не хочу це згадувати!
Мені дуже тяжко!
Не було ще такої допомоги особливої.
Тому ходили, брали десь цеглу розбиту, яку,
як кажуть, повикидали, і будували.
Літо, ніхто нічого на копійку не зробив.
І ось осінь пройшла, ось зима. Уже закидало снігом. І ніхто нічого...
Це село Ягідне на Чернігівщині, місце воєнних злочинів
російських загарбників, що шокували весь світ.
Сніг ховає рештки чорного попелища, яке лишилося на місці
майже всіх тутешніх хат. У березні 2022-го росіяни спалили
тут понад сто сімдесят будинків. Протягом 28 днів окупації
мешканці села змушені були сидіти в полоні
у підвалі місцевої школи.
Ось у цій кімнаті було майже 170 людей. 39 дітей.
Люди помирали, бо не вистачало повітря,
не було чим дихати, їсти не вистачало.
11 мешканців села померли прямо тут, у підвалі, розповідає
свідок подій, шкільний сторож Іван. Росіяни не дозволяли
поховати тіла, тож вони тижнями лежали поруч із живими.
Коли нас визволили, ми другий раз народилися на світ.
Бо ні в кого надії не було, що хтось звідси вийде живим.
Коли ми вийшли звідси, село було повністю розбите.
Будинок пані Тамари за кілька сотень метрів від школи росіяни
спалили перед тим, як відступити з села.
Відтак жінці довелося ще кілька тижнів ночували у тому ж підвалі,
де тільки-но пережила полон.
Ну, я вийшла, бачу, горить. Ну, що? Ну, що я би зробила?
Я ж кажу, що оце якби орки пустили! Спеціально робили, щоб воно
горіло… В інших десь підривали!
Це в мене ванна була. Там двері були в кухню. Це тут було все на веранді.
Це у мене хата. Грубку зробив в тому році кум.
Ось у мене ліжко.
Зараз жінка живе в сараї. Його до війни облаштував зять,
якого росіяни застрелили під час окупації.
Журнал вам зараз покажу. Ось наш підвал. Ось я сиджу.
Оце труби. Отут речі висіли. Страховище було.
Історія окупації села Ягідне привернула увагу міжнародних
благодійників та політиків. Зокрема уряд Латвії виділив кошти
на відбудову даху і стін десятків місцевих хат, серед них і пані Тамари.
Однак коштів вистачило не на все, тому жити вдома пенсіонерка все ще не може.
Латвійці знову ж: приїжджав тут президент, то там зустріч була,
нас із сусідкою не пустили. Нас туди не пустили, щоб ми щось говорили.
Вони тоді пішли в підвал, сходили, сіли в машини та поїхали.
Літо, ніхто нічого на копійку не зробив. І ось осінь пройшла,
ось зима. Уже закидало снігом. І ніхто нічого...
Вони можуть отак от прийти, попитати і піти. І все з кінцями.
Була надія, але наша комісія ТГ сказала що "вам нема". А чого нема?
Все оформили, папери всі… Ну нема, каже.
Пенсіонер Михайло розповідає, що не раз звертався по допомогу
і до місцевої влади, і до членів міжнародних делегацій,
які приїздили у Ягідне, поки ті нарешті не відгукнулися і не встановили
нові вікна у його хату. Інші мешканці зіткнулися з подібним досвідом.
Клала, вчилася цеглу класти, самі будували своїми руками.
Тому що, ну, не було ще такої допомоги особливої.
Тому ходили, брали десь цеглу розбиту, яку, як кажуть, повикидали, і будували.
Купа битої цегли! Он вона ще лежить снігом прикидана.
Оце всім оце починаєш розповідати, мене вже тіпає всю від цього всього!
Ольга каже: якби не волонтери, довелося б і другу зиму ночувати в гаражі.
Стіни, дах, вікна, двері, ну всі ці роботи, які ми не могли
по плану робити, вони зробили. Завезли нам дров,
щоб ми перезимували, щоб ми не замерзли, велика їм дяка!
В Ягідному ми зробили більше 80 будинків.
Наша ініціатива дуже потрібна, бо в найближчі 10 років Україні
потрібно півтора мільйона будівельників. Сподіваємося,
що підхопиться ініціатива і далі буде робитися.
Попри сніг у Ягідному нині ведуться будівельні роботи.
Десять хат відбудовують підрядники, яких найняла держава.
На них тут чекали з квітня - саме тоді село долучили до урядової програми відновлення.
Це експериментальний проєкт комплексної відбудови
шести українських сіл і містечок, що найбільше постраждали
від дій російських окупантів. На Ягідне виділили
понад 400 мільйонів гривень - на ці кошти планувалося відновити
інфраструктуру села та більшість згорілих осель - 118.
Про нас почув весь світ і, напевно, саме через це ми попали
в цю урядову програму. Обіцяли, що проєкт завершиться в цьому році,
в частині приватних будинків житлових.
Але так трапилося, що вони у нас почали роботу десь два тижні тому лише.
За час затримки понад вісімдесят будинків із тих, які планувала
відновити держава, вже відбудували волонтери. Залишилися лише
утеплювальні роботи і покрівля. Будівельники не розуміють,
чому влада дала добро на початок робіт лише тепер, узимку.
Фарбування, наносити фактуру - це неможливо. Тому що це буде брак.
Просто брак. Все. Чого так пізно, взимку, чого не раніше?
Дивно, звісно. Краще б, звісно, коли тепло.
Сказали, що будемо робити взимку. То що нам? Будемо робити!
Комплексна відбудова затягнулася через бюрократичні процедури,
пояснюють у службі відновлення і розвитку інфраструктури у Чернігівській області.
Ось ця ось "бумажна волокіта", так би мовити.
Ну, і плюс те, що це перший такий проєкт, і ми, так би мовити,
першопрохідці у цьому. Більшість договорів уже укладено,
ще частина залишається у невизначеному стані,
оскільки нема там чи документів правильно оформлених,
чи власників немає тут.
Ще одна перепона для завершення комплексної відбудови від держави -
брак фінансування. Ягідному потрібно ще 216 мільйонів гривень.
Та чи будуть ці кошти, наразі невідомо,
кажуть у міністерстві відновлення.
Якщо буде ситуація знову ж таки погіршення на фронті і так далі,
то і ті кошти, які планувалися, мають піти на оборону.
Тобто тут сумнівів нема. Фактично, бюджет наступного року
не має видатків на відновлення. Ми фокусуємося на обороні,
це так і має бути, це правильно, логічно. Розраховуємо на допомогу
партнерів, пов'язаних з відновленням.
Оце ми купили котел за свій рахунок.
Ми включилися якими силами могли.
А зараз ми теж не чекаємо: ми зробили електрику,
ми провели воду, ми провели каналізацію.
Ольга, чию хату в Ягідному частково відновили волонтери, каже:
є де зимувати - і вже добре.
У нас нічого не залишилося: отак як ми були у брудному одязі у підвалі,
отак ми прийшли і побачили це все розбите. У нас з'явилась надія,
що ми колись відродимося з попелу. Надія в нас, щоб була перемога
і щоб був мир! І оцього монстра російського, хворого на голову,
щоб його загнали в кут і знищили!
Оця вся "рашка" щоб пішла на свої землі і не чіпала нас!
Пам'ять про окупацію та знищення Ягідного жителі та місцева влада
хочуть зробити частиною відбудови. У планах - на місці школи
із сумнозвісним підвалом зробити музей-меморіал.
Кожну деталь, каже сторож Іван, тут хочуть зробити експонатом.
Ось такі стаканчики: це нам на двох неповний стаканчик був,
щоб на добу поїсти було. Без хліба.
Ми б хотіли, щоб світ побачив, що воно за нація така, рашисти.
Що воно за люди!